Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想先跟大家分享一个现在正在进行的激动人心的好消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是无休止地用时间换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊发起的“冲刺循环收入挑战赛”。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有志于成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. How can we avoid burnout? And what key times of the day could be triggering us that we
这些原则同样适用于你。丽莎本人还将亲自送出丰厚的奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士一对一咨询一小时的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体账号，或者给我发个私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。我们如何避免职业倦怠？在一天之中，有哪些关键时间点可能会触发我们的倦怠，而我们
might be able to step back from? Let's learn these steps from a qualified clinical psychologist who is an expert in this field of anti-burnout. I hope you find it so useful. Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent. I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Now, we don't want you to burn out, whether you are watching this as an aspiring psychologist or whether you are watching this because you are feeling stressed or overwhelmed. Wouldn't it be great to have a step-by-step guide for how to step back from the brink of burnout and how to keep yourself well? I have drafted in one of my friends and colleagues, Dr. Claire Plumley, who is the author of Burnout, How to Manage Your Nervous System Before It Manages You. She's giving us a very special mini-series over the summer called Burnout Bites, which is all about how to avoid burnout.
或许能够从中抽身？让我们从一位在这个反倦怠领域的专家、合格的临床心理学家那里学习这些步骤。希望你觉得这些内容非常有用。欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。现在，我们不希望你经历职业倦怠，无论你是作为有志心理学家在收看这档节目，还是因为你正感到压力重重、不堪重负而收看。如果能有一步一步的指南来教你如何悬崖勒马、远离倦怠并保持健康，那该有多好？我请来了我的朋友兼同事克莱尔·普拉姆利博士，她也是《倦怠：在神经系统管理你之前如何管理你的神经系统》一书的作者。她在今年夏天为我们带来了一个非常特别的迷你系列节目，叫做“倦怠咬一口”，主要内容就是关于如何避免职业倦怠。
This is episode five in the series of six. There is no need to watch all six. They do build on each other beautifully. So please do take a moment to watch the previous ones and listen to previous episodes if you do like this one too. Let's hand over to Claire and I will see you on the other side. Welcome back to Burnout Bites. This is episode five out of six short episodes all about burnout. My name is Dr. Claire Plumley. I'm a clinical psychologist. I specialize in anxiety, trauma and burnout. I'm based down in Taunton, Somerset, and also have a practice that works online as well. On the 18th of July 2024, my first ever book came out. It's called Burnout, How to Manage Your Nervous System Before It Manages You. And you can get a link to that in the show notes.
这是六集系列节目中的第五集。你不需要把六集全部看完，但它们之间确实有着极佳的递进关系。所以如果你喜欢这一集，也请花点时间去观看和收听之前的节目。现在把时间交给我们克莱尔，我们在节目最后见。欢迎回到“倦怠咬一口”。这是关于职业倦怠的六个短小节目的第五集。我叫克莱尔·普拉姆利博士，是一名临床心理学家。我专注于焦虑、创伤和职业倦怠领域。我的工作地点在萨默塞特郡汤顿，同时也有开展线上业务的诊所。在2024年7月18日，我的第一本书正式出版了。书名是《倦怠：在神经系统管理你之前如何管理你的神经系统》。你可以在节目简介中找到这本书的链接。
So today we're going to talk about protecting yourself from burnout, in particular thinking about the transitions in the day so that you can find those moments to settle your nervous system. I think it's a really good point actually that Marianne has lent out her podcast seat to me here because this is one of those examples of what you can then do when you're tuned into what you need. She has delegated, she's given and trusted me to hold her podcast. Hopefully she feels that I'm doing this in a satisfactory way. And this has allowed her six weeks of space to focus on other things. When you're running something like a podcast, it's really easy to burn out because you're often really passionate
所以今天我们要谈谈如何保护自己免受职业倦怠的影响，特别是思考一天中的那些过渡时刻，以便你能找到那些能够让你的神经系统平静下来的片刻。我觉得玛丽安把她的播客座位借给我坐是一个很好的例子，因为这正是当你对自己的需求保持敏锐时，你可以做的事情之一。她进行了授权，给予并信任我来主持她的播客。希望她觉得我做得还算令人满意。这也让她有了六周的空间去专注于其他事情。当你运营像播客这样的项目时，非常容易产生职业倦怠，因为你通常对这个项目充满热情，
about this project. So this is the kind of thing that hopefully you'll have some more ideas about by the end of this short episode. So you might remember in the second episode when I described the difference between stress and burnout that a sign that we are in good well-being is that we can move in and out of our nervous system gears with fluidity and that one of the signs of burnout is that we are struggling at those transition points of the day. So when we stop or start work when we begin to eat a meal and when we move from you know sitting in the car to getting out and going get the kids or putting them to bed all of these are typical times when you might really notice a strain different activities require different cognitive faculties different levels of energy
所以希望在这个短小节目的最后，你能从中获得更多关于这方面的灵感。你可能还记得在第二集里，当我描述压力和倦怠的区别时提到过，我们心理健康状况良好的一个标志是，我们能够流畅地在神经系统的各个档位之间切换；而倦怠的迹象之一，就是我们在一天中的这些过渡节点上感到挣扎。比如当我们停止或开始工作时，当我们开始吃一顿饭时，当我们从坐在车里出来去接孩子或者哄他们睡觉时，所有这些都是典型的时刻，你会真正注意到紧绷感。不同的活动需要不同的认知功能、不同的能量水平
and movement and so not being able to move fluidly through all of that can cause us real difficulty. So this episode is all about an invitation to notice the transitions in your day. I've made social media posts on this, and I often refer to them as micro moments. So the moment before you start something else, we're often so busy, there's often so many demands on us that we crash from one activity to another. You know, the number of people who struggle with their sleep and yet they're still working on their computers or doing something, you know, work related right up until bedtime. It's a lot. So this is the time if you're beginning to feel burnout or wanting to work on
和动作，因此无法流畅地度过这一切会给我们带来真正的困难。所以这一集的核心就是邀请你注意一天中的过渡时刻。我在社交媒体上发布过关于这方面的帖子，我通常称它们为微时刻。也就是你在开始下一件事情之前的那个时刻。我们通常太忙了，肩上有太多的要求，以至于我们从一个活动直接撞向另一个活动。你知道，有那么多人在睡眠方面苦苦挣扎，然而他们却一直在电脑上工作，或者做着与工作相关的事情，直到临睡前。这太不容易了。所以，如果你开始感到倦怠，或者想要对自己进行调整，
yourself to try and create gaps so you can pace yourself throughout the day. This might be creating gaps even when it feels like there's no possibility of a gap being created. So a classic for me is when I go and get the kids from school. What I used to do is shut my computer down, go and get in the car and park as close to the school as I could so that I could do it all at the last minute. What I found I did when that happened was I was in my head and I was unable to really be there for the kids with whatever they were bringing from their transition coming out of the classroom and you know feeling unhappy that so-and-so said this or the teacher had given them this to do or
现在就是尝试创造间隔，以便在整天的工作中掌控节奏的时候。这可能意味着即使在感觉完全不可能创造间隔的时候，也要创造间隔。对我来说最典型的一个例子就是我去学校接孩子的时候。我过去的做法是关闭电脑，上车，把车尽量停在离学校近的地方，这样我就可以把所有事情都拖到最后一分钟再处理。我发现当这种情况发生时，我的脑子里还在想别的事，根本无法真正陪伴孩子们去处理他们从教室出来、经历过渡时带有的任何情绪——比如因为某某说了什么而不开心，或者老师布置了什么作业，或者
you know I wasn't able to absorb that in a way and be there for them in a way that they needed because I was still stuck in my own head feeling quite irritable that I'd had to break my concentration to come and get them. This was particularly the case when I was writing my book actually and I was really in my flow and really didn't want to give that up. So what I realised was this was not benefiting anyone. We were all miserable. So even though that extra five, ten minutes of writing felt really hard to give up, I did train myself to stop and got used to committing to myself that I would park in a certain place. The kids actually got really used to it and this just became a joyful part of their walk. So there's a little place I can park and it, unfortunately, it walks down the back of a little stream. So I can really use all
你知道的，我无法以他们需要的方式去吸收这些并陪伴他们，因为我还深陷在自己的思绪里，对不得不打断专注来接他们感到相当烦躁。实际上，当我写书的时候尤其如此，当时我正处于创作状态中，非常不愿意放弃那种感觉。所以我意识到，这样做对谁都没有好处。我们都很痛苦。所以，尽管放弃那多出来的五十分钟写作时间让人觉得很难割舍，但我还是训练自己停下来，并习惯向自己承诺我会把车停在某个特定的地方。孩子们其实也很快习惯了，这成了一段让他们感到快乐的步行时光。那里有一个我可以停车的小地方，不幸的是，它顺着一条小溪的背面走。所以我可以真正利用我身边的
of the things around me to ground myself. And there's, you know, rich fodder for me, you know, there's squirrels jumping from tree to tree, there are usually some sort of dog being walked. There's the tree grass, and I try and put my phone either in the car or the bottom deepest pocket of my bag. And I resist any urges to check so I'm not breaking out of this kind of ability to be grounded. So I was having this discussion with someone in supervision recently, and they started to do this with their own clients. And I think something we identified was how hard it is to even notice the transition points when we're so used to kind of crashing from one thing to another without paying attention to them and it's such a familiar feeling isn't it for
所有事物来让自己脚踏实地。这里有丰富的“素材”供我体验，比如松鼠在树与树之间跳跃，通常还能看到有人在遛狗。还有路边的野草，我尽量把手机放在车里或包的最深处的口袋里。我抗拒任何想要查看手机的冲动，这样我就不会破坏这种保持踏实的能力。我最近在督导时和某个人讨论过这个话题，他们开始在自己的客户身上尝试这样做。我想我们发现的一点是，当我们习惯了从一件事“撞”到另一件事而完全不加注意时，要去注意到这些过渡点是多么困难。这种感觉大家都很熟悉，不是吗？
for example everyone to arrive in a meeting a little bit like they've raced there and the thing is you're still carrying whatever you were doing with you so your head's either in the past place you know i've got to do this i've got to remember this and um or what do they say then how will i remember or all these types of worry thoughts about the past. Or we're beginning to think about the next thing. Well, how will I get to there in time? Or what are we going to eat for dinner? Or what will I do when I need to present on this? We're very rarely in the moment. When we pause and have these gaps, this is the time that we can kind of check in with ourselves and ground ourselves. So by checking in, I mean
比如每个人开会时都表现得有点像是赛跑赶到的样子。问题是，你依然带着你刚才做的事情到处跑，所以你的脑子里要么停留在过去，你知道的“我必须做这个，我必须记住这个”之类的事情，或者“他们刚才说了什么，我该怎么记住”所有这些对过去的担忧。要么我们开始思考下一件事。比如“我怎么才能及时赶到那里？”或者“我们晚饭吃什么？”或者“我需要就此做展示时该怎么做？”我们极少活在当下。当我们停下来并留出这些间隙时，这就是我们可以顺便审视自己并让自己脚踏实地的时刻。所谓的审视，我是指
tuning in, scanning your head down to your toes. What's here in my body? You know, am I tense? Do I need to stretch it out? Do I need to move my body and discharge a bit of the energy and adrenaline? Or do I need to just be there for myself? Now, this is typical if I've had a really heavy session of, you know, a client who's really traumatized, maybe I just need to pause. Sometimes then, you know, once you've paused and seen what's here in your body and the quality of thoughts, they're racing or busy or self attacking, I can then do something to meet my need. And whatever that might be, you know, you'll have different tools already in your toolkit. My book also offers more of that. But it might be some sort of self compassion or slowing down or comforting. It might be something more energizing and uplifting so for
调整状态，从头到脚扫描一遍。我的身体里现在有什么？你知道的，我很紧绷吗？我需要伸展一下吗？我需要活动身体来释放一些精力和肾上腺素吗？还是我只需要单纯地陪陪自己？现在，如果我刚结束一场非常沉重的咨询——比如面对一个遭受严重创伤的客户，这通常就是这种情况——也许我只需要暂停一下。有时候，一旦你暂停并看清了自己身体里的状态以及思维的品质（它们是狂乱的、忙碌的还是自我攻击的），我就可以做点什么来满足自己的需求。无论那可能是什么，你的工具箱里其实已经有了不同的工具。我的书里也提供了更多这方面的内容。但这可能是一种自我同情、放慢节奏或寻求安慰。它也可能是更有活力、更能振奋精神的东西，所以对
me for example even though social connection is really really good for all of us and i know i really benefit from it there are times when there isn't anyone to do that with you know when i'm in my clinic i'm on my own but one way i can do that is to look at videos i've got a few videos that just make me always smile they're of my kids being silly and also a little secret here but I do get quite a lot of benefit from watching guinea pig videos and the algorithm has found me and tends to send me lots of funny guinea pig videos when I get home from a heavy clinic there's a half hour gap in the past I have sometimes used that try and do admin but now I know I'm so kind of wrung out from you know holding a lot of emotional distress I try to make sure I use that half an hour just
我来说，尽管社交联系对我们所有人都非常非常好，而且我知道我从中获益匪浅，但有时并没有人可以陪你做这些。当我在诊所时，我是单打独斗的。不过我能做到的一种方式是看视频。我有一些视频总能让我笑出来，它们是我孩子们恶作剧的视频。还有一个小秘密，看豚鼠视频其实让我受益匪浅。算法已经找到了我，往往会在我从沉重的诊所工作回到家后，发给我很多搞笑的豚鼠视频。过去半小时的间隙里，我有时会尝试用来处理行政工作，但现在我知道自己已经被消耗得精疲力竭了（因为承载了大量的精神痛苦），我尽量确保利用这半小时来
have a cup of tea and stare out into the garden or have a cuddle with a guinea pig so I'm paying more attention to what I need and tuning in and actually doing it so using your mindfulness skills and any reset nervous system skills that you already have are really important once you start to do this it might also be helpful to get an accountability buddy or two or three or more, you know, agree with each other. What's the compassionate way of managing our day together? Is it rushing from one thing to another? Is it finishing the meeting 10 minutes earlier? Even if we haven't finished everything on the to-do list or the agenda, actually it's better to have had a conversation that went well and we know we've got that 10 minute to have some downtime and reset together
喝杯茶，凝视花园，或者抱抱豚鼠。所以我更多地关注自己的需求，去调频并真正采取行动。因此，运用你的正意念技能以及你已经拥有的任何重置神经系统的技能是非常重要的。一旦你开始这样做，找一个、两个、三个或更多志同道合的伙伴来互相监督可能会很有帮助。大家彼此约定：我们一起度过一天的富有同情性的方式是什么？是匆忙地从一件事赶到另一件事吗？还是把会议提前10分钟结束？即使我们没有完成待办事项清单或议程上的所有事情，事实上，进行了一次进展顺利的对话，并且我们知道有那10分钟来享受一些停机时间并一起重置，会更好。
it might also be learning some skills in areas that you know maybe you're a little thin on the ground on so for example setting boundaries delegating like marianne has done with this podcast what are the barriers to that is it it about, for example, trust? Is it about feeling worthy of having boundaries and saying no? And is it perhaps practical things like scripts and words and what that actually looks like? So I go through the types of things this might look like at the end part of my book. But I do want to leave you today with a model that I find really, really helpful. It's Susie Redding's model. It's called the eight pillars of rest. And I read it in her book, Rest to Reset. She's kind of given me permission to
这也可能是在你自觉有所欠缺的领域学习一些技能，比如设定边界、像玛丽安对这个播客所做的那样进行授权。这其中的障碍是什么？是因为信任问题吗？是因为觉得自己值得拥有边界并说“不”吗？还是说，这或许是一些实际的东西，比如剧本、措辞以及它实际上长什么样？所以我在书的最后部分详细探讨了这些可能的形式。但我今天想留给你一个我发现真的非常有用的模型。它是苏西·雷丁的模型，叫做“休息的八大支柱”。我在她的书《重置休息》中读到了它。她也差不多同意让我在她的
share it in my book as well. But essentially what she's got are eight pillars that show what you might need if you've been doing something so that you can rethink what rest actually looks like. Rest tends to get pigeonholed as kind of stillness and stopping. But obviously, if you've got a lot of nervous energy, that's not helpful. So for example, she's got a pillar, which is solitude. So if you spent a lot of time on your own, maybe what you need at that point is to fill up emotionally. If you've been moving a lot, maybe it is to come to some sort of more peaceful pausing kind of energy. But equally the opposite is true. So her pillars make it super practical and simple to see what is it I've been spending
书里分享这个模型。但本质上，她提出了八个支柱，展示了如果你一直在做某事，你可能需要什么，这样你就可以重新思考休息实际上是什么样子的。休息往往被归类为“静止”和“停止”。但很显然，如果你有很多神经能量，那并没有帮助。举个例子，她有一个支柱是“独处”。如果你花了很多时间独自一人，也许你那个时候需要的是情感上的充盈。如果你一直在四处走动，也许你需要的是某种更平静、更慢节奏的能量。但反过来也同样成立。所以她的支柱使得看清“我把时间都花在做什么上了”变得超级实用和简单，
my time just doing, tuning in, checking what I need. And here's an example of what might be the opposite of that. So I do hope this has been helpful and that you're able to take some of these ideas and make them really practical and make them your own. I will see you in the final of this short series in episode six, where I'm going to go through the difference between external and internal pressures so that you can separate them out and know where you can maybe do some work on the internal pressures to support yourself thank you so much claire what brilliant
去调频，检查我需要什么。这里有一个可能是其反面例子的东西。我真的希望这能对你有所帮助，并且你能够吸收其中一些想法，使它们变得非常实用并成为你自己的东西。我将在本短系列最后一集的第六集里与大家见面。在那一集里，我将探讨外部压力和内部压力的区别，这样你就可以把它们区分开来，并知道自己可以在哪些地方通过处理内部压力来支持自己。非常感谢克莱尔。你为我们提供的高质量
food for thought you are offering us and how to kind of step back from burnout at those key transition points in the day is going to be so, so useful for me and for everyone who is listening and watching too. Please do come and connect with Dr. Clare. She's Dr. Clare Plumley everywhere. And whilst you're on social media, why not come and connect and follow me too, where I am Dr. Marianne Trent. We are doing beautiful things in the Aspiring Psychologist membership. So please do check that out and do come on over if you think that the time is ready and you're ready for this next step in your career. You can join from just £30 a month with no minimum term. Check out Dr. Clare's book with the details in the show notes and also search for my books, the Aspiring
精神食粮以及在一天中那些关键的过渡节点上如何远离倦怠的方法，对于我以及所有正在收听和观看节目的每个人来说，都将是极其极其有用的。请务必来与克莱尔博士建立联系。她在所有地方都是“克莱尔·普拉姆利博士”。当你在社交媒体上时，为什么不也来关注我呢？我是“玛丽安·特伦特博士”。我们在“有志心理学家会员社群”里做着很棒的事情，所以请务必去了解一下。如果你觉得时机已成熟，准备好迈出职业生涯的下一步，那就快来加入我们吧。只需每月30英镑起即可加入，且没有最低期限要求。请在节目简介中查看克莱尔博士书的详情，同时也去搜索我的书——《有志心理学家
Psychologist Coll collective and the clinical psychologist collective too there's also the grief collective talking head and i have an upcoming book with two of my colleagues looking at people diagnosed with autism who work in the health profession come and let me know what you think to this episode what you think to this series the burnout bites series with dr claire by coming along to the aspiring psychologist community with Dr. Marianne Trent. Please do take a moment to subscribe to the show, to follow the show. It really is the kindest thing you can do for any podcaster and it is totally free. Thank you so much for being part of my world. I'll look forward to bringing you the next episode, which will be
合集》和《临床心理学家合集》。此外还有《谈话头颅悲伤合集》，我即将与两位同事出版一本书，关注在医疗行业工作的被诊断患有自闭症的人群。快来告诉我你对这一集的看法，以及你对克莱尔博士带来的“倦怠咬一口”系列的看法，快来加入玛丽安·特伦特博士的有志心理学家社群吧。请花一点时间订阅本节目，关注本节目。这真的是你能为任何播客创作者做的最好的事情，而且完全免费。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。我很期待为你带来下一集，这将是
the final episode in our Burnout Bites series, which will be available to you from 10am on Saturday on YouTube and wherever you get your podcast from 6am on Monday. Thank you so much for being part of my world and I'll see you very soon. Take care. then let this be your guide with this podcast that you'll find to be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind
我们“倦怠咬一口”系列的最后一集。它将于周六上午10点在YouTube上向你开放，并从周一上午6点起在你获取播客的任何地方上线。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，我们很快就会再见。保重。那么，就让这个播客成为你的指南，指引你走上获得专业资格的道路吧。这就是由玛丽安主持的《有志心理学家》。我叫加娜，是一名见习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现里面所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历真的非常有趣。通往那里的途径竟然有那么多，这让我感到很惊讶，而且成为一名临床心理学家并没有所谓完美的道路，这
of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
让我充满了信心，觉得“不，我没有做错”，从而减轻了对自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。